ob für das abitur das studium oder die
nächste klassenarbeit viele schüler und
studenten lernen falsch das lesen der
notizen am abend vor der klausur ist
genau das was man nicht machen sollte
die fünf besten tipps zum lernen wie zb
das super learning erfahrt ihr jetzt bei
pixum science fiction
viele von euch kennen das die wichtige
klausur ist schon morgen
und dabei hat man bisher kaum etwas
gelernt immer kommt irgendwas dazwischen
man könnte ja mal wieder putzen oder ein
zweites mal mit dem hund gehen ja
verrückte ideen wenn dann abends die
panik kommt lesen sich viele schüler
mehrmals ihre notizen der letzten wochen
durch doch viele studien haben bewiesen
dass ist eine sehr in effektive methode
zu lernen während man den inhalt der
notizen am nächsten tag noch mehr oder
weniger im kopf hat vergisst man das
gelernte nach wenigen tagen schnell
gerade bei fächern wie mathematik die
aufeinander aufbauen kann das extrem
schwierig problematisch sein doch
mindestens genauso viele studien haben
erforscht wie man besser und
nachhaltiger lernen kann die fünf besten
methoden kommen jetzt das gelernte
verstehen klingt simpel ist es aber gar
nicht um sich an das gelernte möglichst
lange erinnern zu können muss man es
zuerst verstehen wer ein thema wirklich
begreift und nachvollziehen kann der
behältnis viel länger im kopf eine gute
technik zum lernen ist den text oder den
notizen einmal zu lesen das blatt
umdrehen und sich dann fragen zum thema
zu stellen
wieso teilen sich zellen überhaupt wie
kam es zu der ausgangssituation vor dem
ersten weltkrieg
selbst wenn man diese fragen nicht
beantworten kann sollte man nicht gleich
aufgeben und den ganzen text von vorne
lesen
man weiß nun viel präziser wo die lücken
sind und was man nachlesen sollte beim
lernen machen schüler auf den fehler
die notizen nur oberflächlich zu lesen
man denkt dass man alles bereits weiß
weil einen die antworten eben in diesen
notizen präsentiert werden dabei denkt
man allerdings nicht aktiv über das
thema nach und es kann passieren dass
man ohne die notizen komplett
aufgeschmissen ist ein guter trick ist
deshalb zu versuchen jemand anderem oder
sich selber das thema zu erklären wie
ein kleiner vortrag wenn man dabei ins
stocken gerät oder der zuhörer am ende
nichts verstanden hat dann muss man noch
mal nachbessern
das gelernte mit bekannten verbinden wie
soll das denn gehen ganz einfach um sich
besser an etwas erinnern zu können hilft
es oft zwei ideen miteinander zu
verbinden
wenn man etwas neues lernen kann man es
leichter abspeichern wenn man es mit
etwas vergleicht oder vereint dass man
schon kennt und bereits verstanden hat
wie zb weiß wie wir hören können also
dass die schallwellen über luftmoleküle
im raum übertragen werden wer kann sich
auch besser vorstellen
die wärme auf atomarer ebene aussieht
und wieso wir uns an heißen sachen
verbrennen können den stoff visuell
aufarbeiten eine weitere geniale methode
um sich wissen einzuprägen ist es sich
etwas visuell einzubringen dazu muss man
die thematik in ein diagramm übersetzen
welcher teil beeinflusst was und welche
kettenreaktionen wird ausgelöst wenn
dieses oder jenes passiert diese floh
diagramme kann unser gehirn viel besser
verarbeiten als einen text der uns die
situation erklären will und wenn man
sich das diagramm auch noch selber
ausgedacht und gemalt hat bleibt es noch
besser im kopf weil es nach seinem
eigenen denkmuster entworfen hat bei
sehr komplexen diagramm kann es auch
helfen sich das bild im zimmer
aufzuhängen so dass man jeden tag
mehrfach drauf schaut durch die
wiederholung prägt man sich das muster
besser ein timing das ist unglaublich
wichtig wenn ihr morgen schon eure
klausur habt dann wird euch dieser tipp
leider nicht mehr helfen können eine
studie nach der anderen hat bewiesen wie
wichtig timing beim lernen ist der
effekt des lernens und verstehens ist um
ein vielfaches größer wenn man dem
gehirn zeit gibt das gelernte zu
verarbeiten
5 x 20 minuten lernen in der woche vor
der klausur sind besser als fünf stunden
am abend vorher durch die dosierung
gelangt das gelernte viel besser ins
langzeitgedächtnis am besten setzt man
sich jeden tag ein paar minuten hin und
schaut sich seine notizen an wenn man
etwas verstanden hat sollte man sich
irgendwo eine notiz machen
ein kurzer satz oder ein diagramm dass
man nur selber verstehen muss quasi eine
quintessenz des gelernten wenn man dann
zwei tage später wieder auf die karte
schaut erinnert man sich wieder an das
was man bereits verstanden hat im
optimalfall kann man so einen
gedankengang auch nach tagen wieder
finden und damit schneller wieder in die
thematik
super learning jetzt kommt eine total
aufwendige methode quatschen ein super
learning ist total einfach und super g
hat nichts mit dem lernen selber zu tun
sondern vielmehr mit den umständen wie
man sich fühlt und in welcher umgebung
man lernt spielt eine unglaubliche rolle
bei der verarbeitung von informationen
eine ruhige entspannte und einfache
musik und zwar nicht laut sondern ganz
leise hilft die geistigen aktivitäten
anzuregen und zu steigern
durch die entspannung steigen das auf
fassungsvermögen und die
konzentrationsfähigkeit zusätzliche
übungen wie yoga oder atemübung können
den effekt sogar noch verstärken
allerdings weiß ich aus eigener
erfahrung dass nur die musik schon
ausreicht um wesentlich besser lernen zu
können beim studium konnte ich mit einer
leichten musik mindern und jeden tag
acht und mehr stunden am stück lernen
und wurde nicht abgelenkt das habe ich
so ein paar wochen durchgehalten und
hatte dann wirklich den kompletten stoff
drin das ist meine empfehlung und noch
ein wichtiger tipp zum schluss die
einstellung macht viele schüler denken
dass ich schlecht in mathe sind und dass
sie daran nichts ändern können es wurde
ihnen angeboren
diese schüler denken oft dass sie ein
gewisses limit haben und sobald es im
unterricht über dieses limit hinaus geht
schalten sie ab aber das ist komplett
falsch
lernen benötigt zeit und energie wenn
man sich mühe gibt dann kann jeder
mensch nach einer gewissen zeit sehr
komplexe und anfangs unmöglich
erscheinende aufgaben bewältigen
man muss nur stetig an sich arbeiten
sich fordern und sich mühe geben aber
mehr von anfang an denkt dass er
schlecht in mathe sein und da nichts
ändern könne
der wird auch schlecht bleiben wer jetzt
direkt etwas lernen möchte dem kann ich
das video zum thema relativitätstheorie
empfehlen gleich ma c quadrat möglichst
einfach erklärt dafür eben hier oben
ticken zu rap und zum blog geht's hier
unten
und was meint ihr was sind die besten
methoden eurer meinung nach zu lernen
wie behaltet ihr die sachen am besten im
kopf schreibt es unten in den
kommentaren vielleicht habt ihr ja noch
einen zusätzlichen trick damit es jeder
lesen kann ansonsten bis dann bleibt